on this episode ET stops by you keep
asking questions we'll keep answering
them my man I always protect you
crazy day here in the city rain you know
a lot of a lot of stuff you don't see on
dailyvee is meeting meeting meeting
meaning I was you know the only bees the
only thing I watch because I have to
double check if there's anything bad or
a criminais ting or the employee stuff
client stuff so much information and I
watch it and I'm always like ah like
this really doesn't show me being the
CEO of vaynermedia it shows me being the
CEO vaynermedia from a cultural
standpoint but not the meaning I just
had with the CMO of Chase or or the
pitch meetings that we have to blur out
that you just saw or you know the
strategy business meetings that I can't
have any other agency out there no and
so not there yet with like you know got
to figure it out because it's you know
it's a day like yesterday and day like
today there's so much CEO work of
building an actual business so try and
figure out maybe you know actually know
what maybe first time I've asked the
question very very cool maybe in the
comments help us figure it out maybe
there's a way where the iraq be rolls it
here's an idea be rolls it shows that it
happened and maybe there's a way for me
to comment on top of it automatically i
don't know there's a final piece missing
here of like the stuff that helps to
come like some of the stuff that I do on
the salesmanship the product strategy
the leading the company in that's right
strategic direction the four or five
things that I've come up with in the
last you know ninety days that are gonna
drive our business the things we're
gonna sell to clients the things that
are gonna help our clients sell things
to you these are real things that are
just not being seen here and and you
know when people ask questions like what
does everybody at vaynermedia do in the
background the planning media the
creating content they're strategizing of
like the snapchat matter for your
business or not you know like they're
they're you know they're doing those
kind of things like you know what does
Instagram stories mean for your business
is there a partnership to be done with
uber
you know how can a your sample
integration into jet comm or if now
Walmart you know real stuff that we're
not getting through here so you need to
figure that out let me know the health
and well-being of my inner circle and
myself first my inner circle because if
my mom was to die in a car accident
today I'm just not sure what I'm gonna
do I don't know that's a truth I care
about it so much more than business that
it would like it probably would make you
unsteady to like know that I believe
that maybe that would mean that I would
not care about anything ever again and
just leave the world like I'm very very
all into like the things that matter I
think it's the way I run this company to
for a culture right like it just cares
so much more about this stuff we're
talking about than any of the other
stuff I and then and then I just don't
want to die I think I could ideally
believe the company's vulnerability is
my health and well-being like my I
genuinely believe that if I walked I
mean this is I don't know how you're
gonna you know all of you don't know me
super well but you gonna have to take
this for what it is I believe that if I
walked across the street in a co-working
if I went to think coffee and started
Gary media that I would put you all out
of business pretty quickly so I know
that says I know that I know that's a
weird thing to say because I know that
I'm being dead [ __ ] serious about
what I'm talking about I'm never scared
about us losing our culture we're not
gonna lose our culture cuz I'm gonna
fire everybody who's gonna hurt my
culture like so like I'm not scared of
anything other than the most important
thing time to go can I get one more
minute how bad is it when's the meeting
start and how far away am i and how long
is the meeting okay
two more minutes
Sky box look at that look at that sky
box where's that where's that that
sports card thing from that time have
you guys seen it do you guys see me
nailing that on the daily be that sports
cards how do you see my sports card
skills like how I knew what year and
what player first question is this don
roose what don't sleep on my skills oh I
have no idea when was the guide Nolan
Ryan shared his rookie card with Koosman
Ernie Banks Roberto Clemente
yes guys guys you all know me this is
the only thing I gave a [ __ ] about for
eight years of my life think about that
much intensity deployed against one
little narrow thing yeah you impressed
right Zach good hey Natalie what are you
doing hey guys hi
Toria I'm Gary Nicholas how are you this
little pleasure yeah how's the tour
going how's Natalie doing sweet right my
door awesome have a great weekend great
day
even well
there's so much so much [ __ ] going on
man I'm always like what the [ __ ]
damn hey guys how are ya how are your
shows you guys having some hits how many
of you cancelled that for the first
episode all right guys are you guys
happy with the way you're going about it
[ __ ] Christ like how fun is it to
have this meeting with that view they're
a bunch of they texted me different [ __ ]
that I haven't answered so why don't you
before when isn't everybody gather up
what they need for me interview
questions like did you see this
musically like great all that stuff
gather all your questions how much time
do I have
good you're gonna all roll in some and
e-50 but for the whole kitten [ __ ]
caboodle so everybody round up like I'm
talking like the texts that are in my
thing like you got to watch this or
approve this like make sure it's dad not
theoretical like life questions it's
been a busy day they're all busy Dirac
how's everybody doing you're tired
I saw you email the last night at
midnight give me some zaps I love her at
12:30
I'm like responding and you're like
scheduling [ __ ] I'm like Tyler hustling
he's like the aunt I said dunk stay
quiet you don't want to get caught up in
there I love that you're a good kid but
you'll get caught up quick in it and the
negative vibe have said you don't wanna
be part of that ecosystem
wait a minute will 1200 two Jet's
tickets do I have for extras tomorrow
should I just go in the slack right now
and be like who wants jets tickets what
so what I mean jet stuff you can't go
and film an NFL game what are you out of
your mind
yes we're gonna be in the stadium I know
I don't want you to do I love it man my
pleasure man when you going back
Saturday hurry man thank you so much
like I think somebody's gonna create a
really cool meme that everybody's gonna
do I don't know what acres yeah I'll
leave I give a [ __ ] about my haircut I
love basketball but I care about my
haircut I can leave at 7:00 10701 thanks
Brit just come her back clear I mean
clearly Garrett doesn't care about his
haircut but I do I just got one more
meeting today bunch of canceled meeting
so Rach you can have a half a day see ya